what the hell are you doing here there
is no game
there's nothing happening here you
clicked on the wrong video please leave
don't ask any questions because there
will be no answers if you can read this
program
if you can read this i can't well i
can't
i literally couldn't read it so i guess
i have to go forward if you can read
this and leave a program too late
are you still here why are you still
here there's literally no game
i hate to break this to you but uh
you're only going to be disappointed
i'm going to keep moving forward in this
and you're going to keep watching
you're not going to see anything special
because there is no game
all right so if you remember back in the
day i think 2015 i think 2015. elixir
and put up a
put up a clip from that what are you
doing here there's no game here
there is nothing to do with terrible i
wish there was five letters then i could
say there is a penis
uh there was a game called there is no
game this is the
fully fleshed version that was a short
like little game this is a full game
i'm guessing this just closes the game
[Laughter]
i i love the game style like just like
it's very counterintuitive and
you know it's a little predictable but i
i still you know there's so much to love
about it
it's not even a little predictable
because there's so many surprises to be
seen from it
anyway uh let's just see where there's
no game here because apparently there's
no game here
[Applause]
game well that doesn't seem right mice
and uh sure
sure sure exit the program immediately
to maximize your chances of corrupting
it's not like this non-game has a hint
system so there's no reason to click on
that icon below to get a clue that would
be too
easy right
[Music]
oh lovely also don't mind this uh this
mark on my nose i almost broke my nose
yesterday i was carrying a chair
upstairs and uh the chair hit the
ceiling and then the chair hit my
nose um so i'm fine i don't think it's
broken but
that hurt hurt a lot anyway boinkis
chapter one of whatever this non-game is
mice and
what is my setup i mean
who's doing all this knocking there's
someone in here
just a minute please uh-huh where's my
speech
oh here it is
i almost forgot the title
don't panic don't panic i won't
why would i panic
oh
hello user hello this is a program
speaking
i've got some bad news oh no audrey
there's no gate that's why
the financial crisis indeed
i hope you're not too disappointed no i
suppose not
to watch tv i don't really do that sorry
i don't do that
i do that yeah there's no game but just
between you and me
avoid asking for a refund if you can
and you know my creator has got to eat
and feed his 12 kids and
his wife who is sick oh
rally finally finds one oh yeah well
probably from having 12 kids
is that thing going to hold i don't know
it's
holding holding well it's been fun but
time to go now time to go of course yeah
well this rope looks weak
can i quit there is nothing to do here
oh really
oh oh try not to touch the title
it's kind of a patch up job uh
oh especially the exclamation point i
was reading out of
my time oh stop you will ruin it
do you have any idea how much mushing
time it took me to stick
all translators out there i've got to
put all that back up
come on ah
the chain is stuck go ahead have fun
i'll give up you give up okay well
that's fair oh
great the break breaker game of the year
yeah what are you going to play after
that pong
snake candy saga
i don't really like those games he's
making some big gestures over there
what you're doing is pointless i'm not a
game program
i'm just oh no
i broke it i'm crapping virtually
thank you completely ruined my beautiful
title it wasn't very good to begin with
well if that's the way things are going
to be let's make something
solid okay sure
ah i might have gone a little overboard
a little janky
if you could just leave the title alone
this time maybe maybe not
how about this is that a chromatic
aberration or is this letter
tilted oh
stop tapping everywhere it's annoying i
can't close the program myself
you have to quit uh sure yeah uh-huh
what if i okay i get it you want to play
your game
all right we're going to play we're
going to play
um uh is that where we hit each other in
the nuts
you know it's the one with rock paper
scissors oh
sure yeah rock breaks scissors
[Music]
paper covers rock and scissors cut
paper okay i always thought here is my
choice
now it's your turn to choose a card okay
i
choose you i win what luck
come on let's play again right right
uh-huh
this is so much fun fantastic i just
know it
oh definitely yeah absolutely
hmm that's too bad you lost again
don't give up oh i would never give up
i know why are you serious
you want to win by cheating have you no
shame
if i were you i would quit the program
right away oh yeah yeah
oops oh no oh no
whoa what
the safety airbag luckily i thought of
everything to protect the game game
no more game here there is game here
is game here is game that's why we're
going to stop now and
you're going to live happy to have
played a fantastic break breaker
and an incredible game of roshambo that
was
not at all rigged no not rigged
what do i have we have something
where did that come from i don't know
it's not supposed to be on the screen
well
it is now i had put it on the top shelf
shelf you say
don't touch it
are you crazy i i couldn't talk at all
ah weird huh it was like i was
suffocating
this is amazing don't touch that icon
anymore
i love your accent
is it portuguese is that a portuguese
accent
lexia
did you make this i guess that's me
assuming that you're the only person in
portugal which is not true
did you make it
are you trying to get rid of me or what
digital assassin
virtual killer
oh i see i see i see i see i got it i
got
oh it not good oh that's not good
oh that's what you're calling you've got
to be kidding me now
look at what you've done a brand new
title if you want to break things
go play battle of duty instead
okay is this where i go play battle of
duty
oh get out of here it's private this is
backstage
ah you shouldn't be here you're going to
catch cold
i'm going to catch cold eh go back to
the title
uh i don't think i will my just what do
you think you're doing
oh you know stuffing things and things
and stuff and uh
no no no no
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow that's amazing
god this is such a charming game it's so
charming
there's something to be done with the
floor mat
oh you know it doesn't matter the key to
this door is on my side
we're too bad where's this key go i told
you it doesn't feed
well i got a key now so that's good
what's over here oh
wait a minute wait why oh
so that actually meant something when
you oh i don't see a
heart not seeing a heart
oh it was a key shape it was key shaped
i'm not 100 sure about that but i got
france i got france in the palm of my
hand
you want france france what's that blue
thing under the
door i don't understand what you're
doing i don't either
that's the thing i i really don't okay
there's something about
getting the key from there i bet but i
think i have to find out more what is
this
all about oh draw me a goat
draw me a cog oh
hello at taking things apart
uh when it's time to leave nobody's home
uh-huh
right when it's down last sentence was a
little weird
i i don't really question anything that
you're saying at the moment because uh
to be honest i i don't really know
what's going on
um you want a cog
oh am i dreaming or are you trying to
pick the lock with the mouse cursor
you just knocked the key that's on my
side onto the floor
let me put it back there we go
oh okay easy hey
no don't do that user i knew something
to do
i'm opening the door
twice actually hope this will calm you
down
no don't bother trying to open it the
lock is completely busted
oh okay all right then
whoa seems to be missing a cog
and a smaller cog too it won't work i'm
telling you
you're telling me all right well tell me
some more moving from screen to screen
no my system doesn't like that i don't
care what your system
goes too fast oh i see
i repeat especially when it goes too
fast
you're stealing from my memory too yes i
don't like that
i like that portion skoosh
man that's not really secure there's
nothing left i can use to help me
i have no choice uh-huh
program loading oh bad luck
you were able to press the button i'm
very upset
now the program is loading and there's
nothing i can do to stop
it you're good you've beaten me i know
thank you
i'm really incredible and intelligent
time to load
oh weird the progress bar stopped moving
no
it's just a myth it even looks like it's
moving backwards now
backwards oh yeah
it definitely crashed i feel bad for you
there's nothing left for you to do but
quit
quit quiet
no i'm a patient man i wait for
loading so long as the program is
responsive
oh hey don't touch my baby
i'm in the progress bar i mean you go
much better like that
no okay don't touch anything stop
already
no hands up don't touch anything else
hands are up
no i don't
the program is going to close due to an
unexpected use
error program closing i probably should
memorize that
i did not memorize it i literally didn't
memorize it
i probably should have and i didn't
blind
[Music]
machine squirrely this is not a fake
operating system
no it looks like mine yeah it looks like
mine you should not open the prohibited
folder
for any reason it's your conscience
who's asking is there something in there
that i should know about
what's skype contact enlarge your
enlarge your what memory
okay all right i'm clicking i'm trying
you're a lonely processor i am find love
and become
a multi-core let's plug together.com
are you fat maybe beef in
bees in whip all right fine there's no
one here
zen whip on tv
you wow shouldn't miss it i shouldn't
go
[Music]
oh my god oh
oh that's nice i actually really like
that
i listen to rainy mood a lot i do like
that
pictures what do we have beautiful water
plus sun equals plant future hazelnut
tree
well that's lovely oh
what oh image two
programming tools
well that's handy thank you i miss three
id card
i bet that says something if you plug it
into a binary reader the restock button
on your machine
seems to be faulty uh-huh
you to hold your finger on it and never
take it off oh
truth the truth about roswell hello due
to a technical problem the content of
this document has unfortunately been
lost
sorry re the fbi yes
oh yes it was a weather balloon all
right
ultra private the truth about kennedy's
death hello
due to a technical problem the content
of this document has been unfortunately
lost
sorry the fbi ps the shooter was a
weather balloon
right the truth about apollo 11 hello
weather balloon the fbi with love
it kisses the fbi
thank you giga private
my conscience is wrong my conscience is
wrong about a lot of things which is why
i don't listen to it and just trust my
gut
now my gut knows a lot more than my
conscience
oh my god jesus christ
holy [ __ ] can i rotate it
oh my god look at that ram oh
oh you you you're 18. this is important
at all i have no
that you're a idea friend of the
environment ah you're going to turn off
your machine
to save electricity
hello hi hello you don't know me
no and my voice isn't remotely similar
to an existing program no
i just wanted to say that these pictures
are scandalous oh yeah i'm going to
contact the authorities right away
regarding the classification of this
game yeah non-game
who are you hey hello lucky page from
start program likes trees kites and the
number 75
that's probably important hates bugs and
goats favorite food the cpu
i don't know if that's a food unless
you're talking about eating
one of the things in those pictures okay
trash
hello thank you
hi worst pinball ever oh
no balls available are no balls
available where can i get [ __ ] here we go
well i lost
yay
oh yeah oh yeah oh what no the ice core
is going to be
bitten what is that why
hey what's wrong with the high score why
can't i have a little fun
what oh
okay all right
[Laughter]
no no no no i'll take that thank you
i'll take that
i didn't cheat you cheated you cheated
password
if i forget the administrator password
enter in this order spot the odd one out
on my id card my favorite number and
miss tokyo's
private number 418. 75 418
spot the odd one out on my id card
id card right what's the odd one out
eight okay 875 418. you should always
listen to your conscience
and your conscience says shut down shut
down shut down shut down shut down shut
down shut down my content says shut up
shut up shut up
goodbye game i have to leave sorry gg
who's gigi who's dd anyway it's uh 8
75 and then
4 18. let me just double check the
picture
oh yeah oh that's 4 18 all right
8 75 14 o'clock your conscience is
telling you that the sun
has just exploded do you already want to
spend your last
eight minutes in front of a screen that
would be a waste
you know why whatever it's i'm gonna die
anyway so what does it matter
might as well get play a little game
maybe pong or something
okay is this where i put this eight
seventy five four eighteen oh yeah
what is he going to do with the system
clock i don't know i hope he doesn't
break
anything i'll take this thank you
oh boom it's pum now okay what did that
do
what did that do ah nut
we need water we need water i can fill
this up with water
maybe is this something that can be i i
have a funny feeling
nutcracker okay that's for later
okay that's for later
[Music]
oh what oh
oh oh whoa
whoa it's teeny it's tincy it's teensy
dinesy
interesting now what do i do with it
your conscience is going to count down
from three
to zero at zero you will fall into a
deep sleep okay
wait oh oh
rain
shake shake oh shake shake shake
shake yeah shake
thank you i don't know if i actually
needed to shake or just tap it but i got
the nut
nut oh you want the nut cracked
[Music]
[Music]
this wasn't planned you were supposed to
leave edges ago
don't do that don't do that i will do
that
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it it's
gonna i'm gonna do it
no i made an implant hey i clicked the
button
from within a fake operating system fake
impossible
fake what's going to
look i don't know what i'm doing half
the time i'm just pressing buttons
if you think that me pressing buttons is
me using my brain to actually think then
you don't understand what goes on up in
here oh hey button
wow namaste user this is the program
speaking
i i have some bad news okay actually
this is not a game
i hope you are not too disappointed you
can still watch a bollywood film
you can walk around the ganges oh dance
ah such a cliche who is it
what are you doing in my game i mean my
non-game what
this is my game i mean mine on game
what are you talking about go away you
should not be here
but user do something damn it don't you
curse with me
accent are you russian russian
do i roar the r like that sir of course
not
overreaction typically arrested i am not
russian
idiot you woke him up oh no what user
you need to quit the program first bye
who are you begging
well hello hi guys hi
don't touch him user he's highly
unstable
the only one who's unstable around here
i is nothing to do with this of course
you do you shouldn't even be here
shouldn't be here but this is what i
live don't fight over me girls
there will be enough crashes to go
around okay
let's just all chill out okay maybe he
will go away
all by himself that makes sense right in
your dreams
uh-huh go on get out of here touch
i touched i touched i died
i'm touching
a fun game non-game not get not a game
got him i did it i win
i won oh hello comrade user
dead news game forbid i hope you are not
too disappointed
yeah not again how do we get out of here
you are spy
okay this one truly has a russian accent
ah you see
but you're still here it seems to be so
human
well
[Music]
touch i touch i'm touching i'm touching
i'm
[Music]
it's changed again i don't understand
what's going on
things are becoming more and more
unstable it's
even raining crossover oh my friends
you are freaked
possibly we could be erased we are all
going to be a race
i'm working on it i'm working on it i
feel crash coming on
oh well you know only if i stop playing
around with this anomaly oh it's not
going to be
pretty
is
[Music]
okay now things are really getting out
of control and besides
there are black cats it's a badass shoot
the crazy cats
[Music]
oh
bang boom
hmm well that's a problem but not my
fault i did everything i could and you
did too
also why are you still here
oh that's creepy
i don't like that
what what happened
i don't know i think i went to sleep
for a minute that's okay everyone needs
a nap
[Music]
i don't know how to break this
i'm not alone okay why on earth did you
touch the bug
i warned you about it i don't know i was
trying to squash it
somewhere i don't know
where
this place is very strange it is very
strange
some kind of television i don't know
maybe we should not touch it maybe we
shouldn't how long is this game i i'm
under sure it just said chapter two and
i'm like oh wait how long is this game
one second
oh my god this is a four or five hour
game
i didn't know that the screen doesn't
have a video signal
oh i didn't know that probably not right
wow there's a lot to this all right i'm
gonna probably i'll get through chapter
two
and then probably end the episode there
and then we can explore the rest of this
non-existent game
later fully this is all i i do love this
though like all jokes aside this is just
super fun
kisses from the gear factory ghost
possession poltergeist miss
voodoo five five five two three six
eight okay ooh
oh you plugged in the video input i sure
did
no you just couldn't help yourself could
you what's wrong with that
i thought i was helping oh interesting
some kind of code system you gonna give
me a
oh
i don't know why i'm doing this but i'm
doing it
yeah you know i do that why not
i wanna
don't tell me you've broken another
coffee cup watson
what son
you called homes
[Music]
is it me or is there an echo all of a
sudden
watson did you hear that affirmative
there was nothing human about that
scream
it seems to be coming from our dear
neighbor wilhelm's home
let's go take a look shall we all of
this is most
exciting
what on earth is going on i don't know
those look like interaction icons
weird i think we're in
the game goodness we can't stay here oh
no
do the icons in the game work are you
afraid of games
oh that can only mean one thing we are
trapped in this world
just like these fictional characters a
world where it's impossible to tell
what's real and what's an illusion oh
don't worry my biggest brain
we've probably entered a different video
dimension don't interrupt me
anything don't interrupt
again at all costs why i fear the
consequences you see
the consequences you fear the shot up
oh you with your blabber jabber this is
mr glitch's fault
he's got something in mind but i don't
know what
uh can i cut these out or something
let's just tear everything down okay
what are you going to do with that stamp
anyway
put it down in an email no no sir
no sorry
oh i licked it i don't know why i licked
it but i licked it
why did i lick it it's been licked
gross put it back on no
it's it's supposed to be a gear right i
believe it's like i stick this on
something that needs a gear that's what
my brain is telling me this goes sticky
stick on something that definitely needs
a gear i gotta figure out how to open
this
okay oh what have you done now
i just cut off a hand you take off one
of the games yeah maybe i did the one
with the bent corner
and just what do you plan to do with
that face well i'm gonna punch you first
so you can stop interrupting me when my
genius is emerging
and then stab in the eye okay the eye in
the tongue
okay you know what fine maybe not i'm
gonna punch these screws out i'm gonna
punch
them out i'm gonna punch them out i'm
gonna punch
punch you don't touch anything here
end up breaking something i did you to
find a way out
i was talking about this dimension uh
well the room is what i did
there's something written on this
strange hatch unfortunately it's too
small to
read what if i get the mug on a flying
glass
excuse me i know i know unfortunately
it's too small to read
okay whatever what's outside
hello i'm markiplier mr wilhelm
open the door it's your neighbor
sherlock holmes uh-huh
it will never work holmes what we need
is a key
hmm the key to open a door
you disappoint me my dear friend be more
creative
make more daring associations and think
in four dimensions
hmm you mean like you're doing now
uh-huh something like that what's on the
ground there there's something on the
ground
there's something on to make a sound
user bam
kaboom stick a punch
i made a sound sound what was that sound
boom
day um my friend
oh he's got a penny it does that whoa
i have a penny now now i have a penny
can i have the penny do i get the penny
can i have penny henny ma'am
oh another penny i'm going to be rich
you'll finally be able to pay your share
of the rent
find me can i get it before ah
maybe i gotta do something before he
gets it so it doesn't
this is big brain time my brain
my brain my brain is working it must be
my brain speaking of yourself my dear
friend my brain okay i'm gonna try this
and then my trip
no yes yes yeah you're mine now
yes stop cheating for goodness sake no
i have the impression that there is
whispering going on around us
a sort of voice with a russian accent
but i'm not there did you hear it
the only thing i heard is the gentle
rustling of the wind
with a russian accent ah of course i
hate it when the wind has a rush when
accents
okay with this penny i can probably yeah
yeah if you certainly have a thing for
tinkerine i sure do
cause i'm so smart one day you'll
appreciate it why not
explain oh where are the monitor secrets
it looks like the set of the game but
sing from the other side
just like most games cobble together
don't you dare go help them out
you don't know what i'm gonna do
hmm point user you're already retaking
i'm really what my bartitsu techniques
have gotten the better of this door
bar what come what titsu or
titsu or titsu go with them
run that by me again hello mr wilhelm
are you there it's far too dark in here
yes i can't be expected to walk around
in the dark sherlock
so try to find us some light watson try
to find us some light
tried desperately wow
lucky let's cross our fingers and hope
that they can't find the light
uh what about this fixing a machine with
a stamp
i'm not sure how that works just in case
i hope it's not connected to a light
source
well what if it was what if it was
now we're thinking in more dimensions
no no no no where's the fake moon going
i hope it's not
you know how it is man you know how it
is yep
that's weird i knew it
watson we can finally see better
i get the feeling that mr wilhelm is
redecorating
but you recall him having a view of the
moon
scares the living daylights out of me mr
wilhelm
are you dead holmes he's floating
watson what has he got in his face
it looks like some sort of relatively
thick monochromatic parasite it's
serious
you're a disgrace to the medical
profession is he a doctor
take a closer look at it i for one would
rather keep my distance from
that thing okay hey can i
uh can i point out that this is
weird what is the what is it
i'm touching it doesn't look like it's
pretty in any ways
right of course not plugged in of course
what was that sound like a ringing belt
it's a telephone i think
it came from this odd device you don't
know what telephone is
oh yes mr wilhelm told me about it it's
a prototype of antonio muchi's
teletrophone
it allows you to communicate with
another person from a distance
instantly i say and how many of them
exist
this is the only one of its kind well
then who can no there has to be two
you're it's useless it's useless yes yes
no more playing around no you go back to
the room we started
now we might be able to find our exit no
no no
[Music]
i do i do but i need to get
it i need to get it how do i get it
i'm going to punch the phone i'm going
to punch watson oh
i didn't know that's how that did punch
punch me in the eye
and a good slap in the face
oh i can see the back of this one oh if
you were thinking about moving that fake
wall
forget about it i'm moving x on the
ground sure that a piece of rail is
missing
or a letter of the alphabet
my money is on the piece of rail or a
letter of the alphabet you say
oh it looks painful
[Music]
what red letter oh
[Laughter]
all right here's what you meant by
letter of the alphabet i
get it you'd have no business with being
in my business wait uh did you just use
a letter from anonymotopia to fix
yes but that doesn't make any sense yes
you might as well use
i'm gonna remember that but what really
gets me is
that it works you don't know that oh it
worked hey
look at that
uh oh
oh just swiped their mining fine glass
the waste wasn't enough for you
well you know i just hope they won't
figure it out the fist is never enough
for me
i told you i had my magnifying glass in
my hand
and it suddenly disappeared there you go
they're figuring out that voice it's the
ghost holmes
the russian ghost but i'm not
russian mr wilhelm you never told us you
were such a talented ventriloquist
oh he's not the one speaking i am
my name is game
i'm a computer program i'm with a user
a human and we are trying everything we
can to get
home do you know how we can exit your
game
game what game
[Music]
your game you are aware that the world
you're in
isn't real not you oh
oh you don't know that you're in a video
game is that it
uh oh i'd rather look for my magnifying
glass than continue listening to your
mad
jabbering mr wilhelm but he's not the
one
user i think we are going to need mr
glitch's help
why do we brought us into this dimension
he will probably be able to get us out
of here well
what's a video game there's got to be a
way to get it off
maybe some kind of ritual ritual yeah
let's go
ritual for the fire department why would
they
why would they be able to help dev only
one more rule you're going to be able to
break
it could be devious only punch it
punch it chewy punch it punch it okay i
pressed it
would have been cool to punch it like
literally just wallop it but
how
yes oh i think i know where we are
ah it's a dictionary right this is where
all the things that are used in the game
are told i know what that means
of course whatever that means can happen
access okay there's ice cream back there
i'm gonna go get it
yes give me the ice cream
ice cream iced cream i would like the
iced cream
could i have the iced cream ice cream
for ice
cream this didn't help me i'm not
helped i haven't been helped
okay think about this okay think with my
brain
there's something about colors here dip
my fist
in the colors there is something about
the colors though
them colors go
i see almost
too easy i get it it's so obvious
it's painfully obvious man anyone who
couldn't understand this
would be a real buffoon ice cream if i
get the tongue
i can lick the ice cream and then it'll
be good
what if i turn out the lights again
if i turn out the lights what if i what
oh
oh interesting
but but wait user i think
you've lost the night yeah but wait i'm
going
to be sick
in this corner i say there's a bit of
light over by the entrance
i may have lost my magnifying glass here
uh maybe
mayhaps hey stop covering up the thing i
need to
get stop covering the thing i need that
thing
you give me that thing if you don't give
me that thing i'm gonna get that thing
from you
all right fine i see how it is all right
i got the eye let me go
you see what i do what that i
do though what that i do
oh a big red bull like a juicy cherry i
don't think that's what that
is oh oh yeah
uh-huh
okay all right uh
i know what to do with a colored ball
oh yeah i know exactly what to do with a
colored ball
we all know what to do with a colored
ball what if i replace the moon with the
sun and then it'll be so bright
i'm gonna make this ball yellow and then
it will be the sun that's how
logic works right i'm so smart
so smart watch this it's now the sun
boom put it in the sky okay and that
didn't work
can i punch the moon i stab the moon
look at the moon
okay so logically speaking what do i do
with a ball what would i do with a ball
maybe i have this too soon maybe i maybe
i'm out of order on the ball
huh yeah uh-huh what if i give the
magnifying glass
back can i do that no i don't think i
can do that
all right i will not get a hint i don't
need a hint
i don't want to hint no hints for me
please
you can do something with the moon it's
clear
you can do something with it
no i knew that mining fine glass was a
good idea oh
frontier is strange oh it's fine
it's like a missed puzzle yeah wait okay
wait i got there's a number
there's a number on the side of the
computer five five five two three six
eight got it
five five
five two six
three eight
what five five five two three two six
three eight
two three six eight darn it three
six eight
[Music]
i can get it now it's my chance it's my
chance
are you a video game too
yes three steps for a successful
disenchantment
i'm listening ah that's what we're
interested in
yes there must be a full moon
as luck would have it it's not the case
cover the victim with snow it's the
middle of may
then gently place large cherry on top
the east is a ritual or a cake recipe
so let me summarize uh-huh full moon
full moon
yes big cherry thank you madam we are
screwed
full moon you say a full moon you say
well first off a give and the award
of the year
you and your sass can just you know stop
thank you but also uh shut up
it's gonna be a full moon all right i'm
gonna blap that i knew it it was just
slightly out of order oh
boy oh lick it let's go lick some ice
cream that's what i wanted to do
ice cream i know i
know it's just water in the solid state
i know
[Applause]
uh yeah very strange i don't know you
know i but i had ice cream so i'm happy
with my life
and my life choices these kinds of paint
make me think of the three primary
colors uh-huh yes red
blue and yellow i know except we're
inside the cathode ray screen
with a video signal which is a mix of
red
blue and green uh-huh without a paint
brush there's no point anyways
without a paintbrush you say why am i
talking about mixing colors why
are you talking about mixing
colors why don't you shut up
why don't you let me do big thinking
brain
i got a cone holmes
i'm completely in the dark i'm terrified
yes excellent if you see my magnifying
glass let me know
i hate you
it's doing something to it it's
it's clearly this is a thing to do you
lick the moon i don't know
why it is licking the moon
the moon is being licked
yellow gross what a fantastic full moon
i hope the game won't get wise to us no
way
we're too smart that's a phenomenal full
moon
now i need a big red cherry
wow look at that full moon
no snow right snow definitely need the
snow
who wouldn't need snow i know where to
get snow oh don't you worry about snow
i got snow two hours later
wait wait oh my god wait
oh oh my god
oh no jamie snow
i'm impressed user let's hope that this
snow will do the trick oh my god i did
that with my own brain
i did that with my own brain my own
brain
oh sorry mr wilhelm
all right for your own good i think i
think too put a cherry on top
okay we have all the ingredients ignore
that that's an eyeball
that's not happening happening
mr wilhelm just exploded like a beached
whale
perhaps he was allergic to cherries i'm
finally free of that ridiculous pride
this trip has been more difficult uh-huh
[Music]
gg like his ex we have to follow him
uh but this painting just blocked away
impossible i feel like
it's backwards are you talking about
your trousers my good man
how are we going to get busted uh
now the painting is the right way around
at least i think so
uh-huh the passage is open again yes
come homes
let's follow the rainbow ghost tom come
in watson it's probably just a large
flying insect
probably if i understand right
some things seem to be affected by this
bug fragment ah
it's like it reverses them or something
ah
who cares let's follow them ah
who cares yeah who can't hide
hello it's somewhere
but why you are not happy here with your
new
did not npcs that sorry i meant
new friends watson stop conversing with
this beast
you're making me uneasy doesn't seem too
great
where are you trying to go mr glitch to
a place where
i will be able to unleash my evil plan
now you shouldn't have evil plans
the one that will let me oh
what what did he say a copy protection
system right in the middle of a game
yeah let's find the numbers we need fast
user
okay all right kane and bomb kane bomb
kane to the bomb okay kane bomb six one
five
wait
[Music]
i don't it don't do six there's clearly
a problem oh
interesting very interesting
oh no no no no this is fine
so that looks like a five but that don't
look like a six
so i need to find a way to make one of
these look like a six
and the only way to do that is
to go okay so we just now we just need
to
i mean i think that's still the right
thing yeah the lowest number oh
okay so we need gun skull
skull gun easy
three one five
bam oh my brain oh hey wait
no stop stop what an evil plan ah
isn't it could you say that again we got
cut off yeah we got cut off
there i just saw the exit which
maybe i will okay
farewell rainbow butterfly he
disappeared into the ground
wait this goes underground doesn't this
let's have a look around
oh well now that's right side up is that
good
is that a good thing
i didn't do it that wasn't me
watson where did the characters go oh uh
oops oh
hello sherlock i'm going to
fall hold on watson the world is
ending everything is fake i
am fake london is probably on a fault
line
i'm going to get us out of this mess
darn it
we can't leave them there like that i
mean we could let's try to get them to
safety quickly before leaving
you know you know how it is you know i
mean
do whatever does it really matter
oh wait the bathtub right this is this
bathtub oh
bathtub hub
hob bam oh cover doesn't want to move
at least not from this side are you
so smart you so
smart you're showing me up boink
there you go it wasn't that hard we just
opened the passage for you
go ahead mr horns jump well jump
something for you to land
in on the other side uh-huh jump jump
hold on watson
how is that gonna jump over to the hole
it's not really a jump
two one well done
[Laughter]
but the jump animation must have been
amazing
around
oh look at that cutie
oh
[Music]
okay legend of the secret
ah this still isn't our dimension no
it's not
getting home is going to be more
complicated than i thought yeah maybe a
little bit
all right so that is uh that is it for
this episode um
if you want to see the rest of this game
definitely let me know down in the
comments below it's a niche game i don't
know if it's going to lose its charm
over time but it hasn't for me
uh it's it's a fascinating thing i
really do like this and i'm
i i'm thrilled that he actually turned
it into something bigger and better
uh so if you want to check out the game
for yourself i'll put a link in the
description below
and then again just let me know if you
want to see the end of it because it's
really fun
so thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you